le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
parmi les particularités de l'île de la
ruée de notre île un endroit unique au
monde en effet l'île de la Réunion est
souvent cité en exemple de par la
coexistence de plusieurs ethnies
religion et culture
cette richesse multiculturelle et
culturelle qui fait aujourd'hui la
fierté de notre département vient d'un
passé pour ton douloureux
ces cultures et religions ont été
déracinés dans le passé alors comment
rester en contact avec ses propres
racines sans rien oublier mais sans
communautarisme on en parle maintenant
dans les associations
si tous ces marmailles sont calmes et
concentrés c'est juste qu'ils sont en
train de voyager tout en restant sur
place cela paraît improbable mais c'est
pourtant le cas en effet ces jeunes
enfants bénéficient d'une activité
ludique et enrichissante à la
Bibliothèque Départementale de la
réunion à travers différents ateliers
ses enfants voyagent intellectuellement
et découvrent les traditions et les
cultures d'un pays ces travaux manuels
auxquels ils participent leur permettent
de mieux connaître l'Inde un pays qui ne
leur est pas indifférent car l'Inde fut
l'un des berceaux du peuplement de la
Réunion
depuis l'année dernière l'école
maternelle centrale est associée au
programme que propose la Bibliothèque
Départementale de la Réunion il
s'agissait pour les élèves de découvrir
de réaliser un petit carnet de voyage
sur les îles de l'Océan Indien
ils avaient une visite mensuelle cette
année l'action a été reconduite avec un
autre petit projet il s'agit pour eux de
cinq visites qui tournent autour de la
découverte de l'Inde donc ces voyages au
pays de l'Inde et les enfants sont
accueillis là-bas de façon magnifique
ils ont
d'abord une petite lecture qui lui
aurait faite par les bibliothécaires et
ensuite un petit atelier artistique
voilà donc pour cette année il réalise
une boîte à bonheur dans laquelle ils
mettent des petits travaux manuels voilà
autour de petites réalisations sur
l'Inde donc les enfants
en sachant si oui d'être en centre-ville
et de pouvoir fréquenter un lieu de
culture tel que la Bibliothèque
départementale donc ils ont pu
comprendre qu'une bibliothèque c'est pas
simplement un meuble dans une classe et
même une salle dans une école mais bien
un bâtiment un bâtiment dédié au livre
et à la culture donc ils sont très bien
accueillis là-bas ils ont une belle
attitude quand ils y arrivent ils savent
ils savent qu'on y respecte le silence
on marchaient pas de velours et comme le
cadre et tout autre très accueillant
et bien ils sont tous oui et ils ont à
chaque fois une petite lecture ou
plusieurs des petits poèmes qui leur
sont fait autour de l'Inde pour cette
année on met en place c'est magnifique
parce que il
sont ils ont le goût de la lecture ils
sont attentifs quand on lui en fait des
petites lectures à l'école et ils ont
surtout
maintenant dès que je leur fais une
petite lecture toujours besoin du
référent planisphère dans mon dos
en faisant travailler la curiosité des
jeunes enfants il est bien plus facile
de les intéresser et par conséquent de
les faire avancer à travers le voyage
intellectuel ses enfants s'enrichissent
découvrent et après sur une destination
un pays un copain cette façon efficace
d'aider à l'éveil des enfants dépasse
largement le cadre de la Bibliothèque
départementale ou des autres équipements
culturels du conseil général puisque
cette année cinq collèges voyagent dans
les cinq pays d'origine du peuplement
réunionnais
nous faisons partir des collégiens en
Inde cette année ils voyagent et là des
classes maternelles avec la Bibliothèque
départementale et leur professeur
renseignant nous leur faisons voyager je
crois que c'est non seulement un beau
travail mais aussi une façon de
s'approprier une part de notre culture
indienne parce que l'Inde vit à la
Réunion c'est la richesse que nous avons
sur cette belle île une unité culturelle
dans une diversité beau voyage dans
l'imaginaire de ces enfants
grâce à la Bibliothèque départementale
la jeunesse réunionnaise peut bénéficier
d'activités extrascolaires utile au
développement et à l'ouverture d'esprit
des jeunes enfants un outil plus
qu'apprécier par les professeurs
soucieux de soutenir au mieux les rêves
et les ambitions de leurs élèves c'est
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des outils
culturels du conseil général qui s'ouvre
ainsi vers le monde éducatif pour le
bien-être et l'éveil de nos enfants
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais